Throughout this course, we will be
using materials drawn from a number of
different textbooks and papers.
You'll find specific references
to all these sources for
this examples in the Class Notes.
Generally, however,
we will use a handful of books from
which we will draw a lot of material.
Artificial Intelligence
by Patrick Winston.
Knowledge Systems by Mark Stefik,
Artificial Intelligence by Elaine Rich
and Kevin Knight and Artificial
Intelligence: A Modern Approach
by Stuart Russell and Peter Norvig.
You don't have to buy
any of these books.
But if you want to increase your
knowledge beyond what we'll discuss in
this class, you may want to
consider both these text books and
the specific references at
the end of each lesson.